award-winning chef dan Kluger one of the
nicest people in New York City believes
everything should have a purpose his
love of cooking began here in New York
helping his father in the kitchen and
watching cooking shows on TV years later
he became the guiding force behind some
of New York's top kitchens including
Jean Georges ABC kitchen where he won a
James Beard Award for best new
restaurant and best new chef on her from
food and wine last year he opened Loring
place named after the Bronx Street where
his father was raised the decor is
simple and elegant and the dishes are
fresh and seasonal chef Dan Kluger
welcome to the dish good morning so nice
to be here so happy to have tell us
about this table so we got a mix of
things from our menu we have a
wood-burning grill wood-burning oven so
we use the wood-burning grill to impart
a lot of flavor and vegetables make it
kind of meaty another dimension so we
have wood-burning grill broccoli right
here with pistachios and orange and then
we have some roasted beets with some
fennel and smoked goat cheese and then
one of my favorites for the season is
sugar snap peas and some of them are
also grilled on the wood board and grill
Wow
and then we use a local cheese to make a
vinaigrette and then of course we have
some pork chops and the pork chops are
glazed with pomegranate and they're
served with cabbage fennel some chilies
we like to add a lot of chili as an acid
to the food a lot of this is driven by
the green market yeah so we about your
relationship with local purveyors of the
season we try and cook seasoning
whenever possible using all these local
farmers and working with three years
again a lot of them are at the farmers
market Indian [ __ ]
Hudson Valley Long Island etc and we
just try and take what they have put a
little twist on it make a little more
delicious and exciting I was surprised
that that you started out studying to be
a physical therapist but you took a
little turn because you have to you have
to study nutrition yep they said the
best thing because we don't have an
undergraduate program but we have an
amazing graduate program do nutrition do
some food serve classes get a degree
you'll learn what you need to in order
to be ready for the graduate program and
somewhere along the way I met Danny my
I did an internship at Union Square cafe
and this was at Syracuse this is that
Syracuse su and I got bit by the bug and
been in the kitchen more or less since
then you given your relationship with
Danny and jean-georges I mean two of the
great New York chefs would you learn
from them each one totally different
things but at the same time so many
underlying themes I mean both incredible
business men John George taught me so
much about business and just how to look
at it from a different angle Danny
taught me and curved them out of my
hospitality and that and just how to
take care of people and and how to
really make them feel like they're
sitting at your table yeah in 2014 sorry
I interrupted my drink there what is
that drink by the way tell us because
it's lovely float this is a thoroughfare
it's basically our version of a dark and
stormy we use local rum from upstate New
York we make a special lime syrup and
again it's pretty much a dark and stormy
but our version in 2014 you go off on
your own a little scary going off on
your own incredibly scary yeah what did
you decide to do it it just felt like it
was the right time I knew I wanted to
open my own restaurant and had spent
plenty of time at all the places I had
worked and so it felt like it was time
to do something and I had a lot of
support from friends and family at that
point in time that made it while scary
made a little more doable and evict the
ante or actually to up the ante I mean
the opening of alluring place was one of
the most sort of talked about events in
the New York food calendar what's it
like to have that amount of pressure on
your first solo endeavor I mean it's
it's amazing it's very flattering
ultimately I just wanted to open a
restaurant
yeah without the pressure yeah it's it's
an added pressure but you know at the
same token it's a blessing and a curse
you know if I didn't have it when those
would be so I'm really appreciative that
so many people were following us and
checking in and wanting to be part of it
tell us about the name so the name was a
long search for finding a name and
trying to find something that had some
meaning but not a whole lot of meaning
and wasn't going to be some that we just
threw against the wall and came up with
it and after many many iterations I was
talking with one of my sous chefs and he
said to me tell me a little about your
father my father just passed away and we
were talking about different things and
the name Lauren place came up and that's
the street he grew up on and it kind of
went in the back of my mind but didn't
really think much about it and literally
the next day my cousin sent me a text
saying I was just cleaning out the Attic
I found something of your father's and
it's his yearbook you should check it
out and it says Arthur Kluger Loring
place I was like you know what this is
the name that's it it came to you and
the logo and everything is actually his
writing from that your great shout out
to pops yeah exactly I will note that
there are also delicious cookies on this
table which Anthony and I are gonna
pound as soon as this segment is over
I'm gonna pass this to you chef as we do
each time we come chef on the dish and
ask you to sign it and also ask you if
you could share this delicious banquet
with anybody past or present and who
would it be I think would be my family
my father for sure and then the girls
because I just loved the interaction of
them yeah it's a nice thing chef Dan
Kluger one of my favorite people in New
York City
thanks and congrats on all this exactly
and for more on Jam Kluger and the dish
head to our website at CBS this morning
calm